what's the difference between distance  and displacement distance is simply how  much ground an object is covered and  displacement is how far out of place an  object is so if an object starts at  point a and moves around like this and  reaches point b then this ground covered  is called the distance and this shortest  straight line distance between a and b  with this direction is called  displacement if an object starts at a  goes around like this and returns back  at a then what will be the distance  covered and the displacement  this length covered will be the distance  and the displacement will be zero  because the object is not out of place  displacement is basically the object's  overall change in position in a  particular situation when an object has  moved can the displacement ever be  greater than the distance share your  answers and do share this video with  your friends and family  [Music]